today on our show we are going to talk
about wonderful box office and we're
going to talk about a box office that
perhaps isn't so wonderful yes it might
be wrapped up in a problem someone might
need to call their mummy hmm eyes stayed
buried
he's still going what the highs and lows
of not just the box office summer but
also puns this Kevin and Mark today I
thought now that man
that men on Batman yes that minute
Batman Kevin I am mark barnard me okay
man
we're in your news right now when I
analyze and taking a look hot takes on
old news time we get about time you
watch this happen alone or do is we take
it out of fridge we were claiming it
putting it on the oven just fizzling it
up a little bit reheating we're giving
you leftovers and sometimes those are
great meatloaf on P two breeds of white
bread holy sháá that's what this episode
of fat man that means the meatloaf
sandwich on two pieces of Wonder Bread
and who don't [ __ ] like that much
you're vegan we hunt takes there it is
hot pockets today we're trying to brand
this pregnant like we read about okay
well I will tell you the one woman is
not old news that's new news it's new
news because we're talking about not
only has it already made
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah 138 million
domestically as of today okay it will
make another 50 over the weekend but
they giving up a level one movie again
it's going to kick the share the money
but look of the mummy will get there it
will have also makes 300 million
worldwide
a lot of [ __ ] money imagine there is
a time somewhere people like to think
anyone will go to 101 elite hmm now
you're gonna get a boatload of them
right they'll never stop coming and in
perspective Wonder Woman get better at
the box office its first week then
behind man
no and Thor ba and Captain Merrick but
Baba that's true yeah even adjusted even
adjusted as far as solo Marvel the first
appearances of those guys
Wonder Woman outperformed now to be fair
she had something on Iron Man Thor the
other one Captain America
she had something on all three of those
dudes and that is the fact that nobody's
ever done a standalone superhero woman
movie we are going to caveat Supergirl
okay fair enough and that's true glad
we're doing this
yeah 25 years ago alright and I don't
[ __ ] 30 years ago probably was point a
good point that's fair you have to go
back 30 years to find it and they also
didn't release it like they released
this movie this was a worldwide event so
it's making all the monies its projected
to make all the money this week
I've read something this week where that
said Eddie Jenkins not signed for the
sequel but I'm sure yeah that Warner
Brothers is rectifying that as we speak
it's gonna cost him money to verify it
but good for that you get that story
that she had to fight for the no man's
land sequence really yeah then Warner's
didn't want that in the movie though
like how we don't quite get the point
can we just skip past this that's the
movie that's the [ __ ] Wonder Woman
no-man's land
Mike Schuh Duggar Hilton was like if we
don't have this we don't have a movie
pun intended
that is a beautiful sequence my god she
fought for it patty Jenkins not like you
know the most obvious choice because the
last theatrical feature she had made was
monster run she's got a lot of episodic
television work and whatnots not like
she hasn't directed since monster
monster was 13 years ago and boom she'd
take this movie and turns it into
exactly what it needs to be and
everybody's happy and there was much
rejoicing but the story that moral of
this story is anybody you don't know
where the next great blockbuster maker
is going to come from like you know I'm
sure if you ask patty Jenkins four years
ago I think you'd ever make one of these
comic book movies No yeah or no they'd
never come to me now the game has
changed now because patty Jenkins
shatters a glass ceiling you're going to
see more women directing material they
probably should
there's no way and held out that Miss
Marvel isn't directed by a woman you
know they have that I think it is not
Captain Marvel Captain Marvel I think
they've announced the directors we got
the model
it's a pair oh one of them is sharing I
know - Anna Boden I think it's best if
the Half Nelson got down some kids write
them yeah I'm truly strong but like and
I think this also gets shine the light
on the fact that it took her 14 years to
get a second movie made this being her
second movie why does it take 14 years
for a talented filmmaker like this to
get her second film I'll tell you why
because she's not trying to make tuskor
you losers I'm you got to lower your bar
kids yeah don't hold out for good
material
yeah but I make whatever you can it is
one of those things where you you begin
to look at the totality of the way
Hollywood works
people like Colin Trevorrow you know
makes a tiny little movie called
whatever safety not guarantee that goes
to some minutes does really well then
gets Jurassic world then gets a
strollers movie and that's like a
five-year clip John watts about the
guy's name a good cop car and spider-man
homecoming yeah amazing you know like
just patty Jenkins fresh-faced right off
of Monster than 13 years ago he's like
directing actors to an Oscar like
clearly has talent aptitude for the game
and it takes her 13 years for movie
number two well the good news of this
valley Jenkins day never gonna have to
wonder where the next jobs coming from
nope the van or scripts from now until
the end of time she'll be able to do
whatever she wants which is a lovely
thing she is the true Wonder Woman in
the situation so much praise to her now
what do you think they should have we
think they should go to sequel does this
going to be a sequel like let's be clear
I've said before like cheetah but you
know you can't like they showed her
fighting World War 1 mmm her fighting
another lady who episode I said might be
a bit of a comedown this may be Cheetahs
one small part in opening of something
I'll take that the opening of Wonder
Woman to is a [ __ ] chasing down
cheetah and they get into a fight and
then she's like I remember World War two
and then we go back time again but I'm
all for that but I don't care where they
take as long as bad Jenkins directing
that as long as gal gadot playing that
part I'm [ __ ] her Chris well orders
one spoilers 5 countdown 5 4 3 2 1
you know unless he's a [ __ ] force
ghost one of the most enjoyable aspects
of the whole [ __ ] you know
Wonder Woman flick was Chris Pine and
now he's gone well I'm sure that you
know the DC Universe has a shape-shifter
or two they could maybe get into it
especially if you do a thing where you
just know almost made me cry that's how
they can introduce Martian Manhunter and
[ __ ] like that boom I I was trying to
think of like I'm in love with a Wonder
Woman sequel that does not take place in
the contemporary universe I think you're
on something like I think I think
there's a world in which you do the Cold
War you do the 50s you do Russians you
set the Martian manhunt
that you did and she sees this guy who
looks like kernels like looks like Steve
Trevor's and um I got [ __ ] goose
bumps right now like I feel like it
sorry when is your movie come out
because I want to give you all the money
for it that's a good [ __ ] idea dude
that will allow you to get Chris Pine
into the movie movie and like yeah you
know as you're playing the Martian
Manhunter Letta beep but it allows you
to bring that character into the play
and in a way that is not villainous in a
way that like because Marshall may know
there's a hero in soup Trevor's a hero
that there's the I'm feeling some
affinity for this person who I know
can't be that person you know where I
discover isn't that person but I don't
hate them because they're not that
person because you're still a [ __ ]
hero oh it's just like at the end of the
movie and she rides to Bruce Wayne thank
you for bringing him back to me you get
almost it
I hate when we do this we get real
excited about a movie that doesn't make
god and I bought it I would sit there
going yeah said yeah I got money
good [ __ ] story you should at least
do that in common but also I like the
idea of not bringing her contemporary I
like her keeping a little - Justice
League movie yeah like that's fine but
like let's leave her pockets where she's
not infected by the rest of the universe
where she gets to be pure Wonder and
there's no like well why doesn't
Superman just show up there's another
[ __ ] not there yet I've been doing this
[ __ ] since he was in [ __ ] short pants
yeah and they took him out of short
pants for these hmm that was all one
body thing and then you do the next
movie in Vietnam and then you do it
where she sees the [ __ ] the
Kryptonian Comet come through and streak
into the land in Smallville [ __ ] why
why isn't she the watcher of the DC
Universe where she's seen the world
unfold as we know it the chronicler of
Legends
why aren't you in charge oh god no no we
were doing oh my god that sounds amazing
sadly it's just in our imaginations oh
hey kids sometimes the best movie is the
one your friend comes over while you're
recording a show
live in York [ __ ] that was good
all right hon we're on I'm depressed
about real so you know what wonder woman
this weekend will beat the [ __ ] out of
the mummy yeah let's talk we're
recording this on Friday you'll be
seeing this next week see a sad result
of this weekend's box office will be
known to you and not death but right now
in the past move on to you in the future
yes they're telling us they could do
very well the projected opening based on
the Thursday night and Friday numbers
like 32 million is the upper started at
40 couple weeks ago and first came out a
tracking mom is going to do 40 in people
like wow that's weird it's Tom Cruise
movie yeah come here another reviews
dropped on Tuesday Wednesday yeah like
man oh man like they were yoga hosers
bad but yoga hosers didn't spend nearly
as much to get these reviews yeah we
made it at a discount independent of
whatever the movie cost and looking at
it is probably about 120 130 million
dollars they spent double that on
advertising which I mean what yeah it's
everywhere here in town and feels like
it's everywhere in the world as well
billboards all over town lot of
advertising on TV I'm going to watch a
youtube clip I'm forced to watch a mommy
commercial so Universal is gambling big
on the dark universe the birth of the
dark universe we haven't seen the movie
yet but from reports of those who have
seen the movie including critics you
know a lot of the reviews have been
really just not good me yeah and not
like me and like critics oughta hold
back were just like they're like on
hospitality business but they talked
about like there's a logo for the dark
universe film at the beginning of the
movie and a lot of people were like
that's hubris like Marvel earned a
Marvel Universe Studios logo that showed
off all their characters and
interconnections over the course of the
decade like and they remember the story
when iron men first came out and they
began screening it for fans for critics
for everybody cuz they knew they had
something great they then when it shot
that last clip that says I want to talk
to about the Avengers initiative they
were not I mean they had in the back of
their heads of course but they didn't
know if they could pull that off and at
the very last minute and Bo
than by response did they decide [ __ ] it
let's go for it these guys come into it
the last thing that the [ __ ] cherry on
the cake like oh by the way before we
turn the lights off let's throw a little
PS tag on the movie came to define
Marvel films yeah the last idea last one
and the first one on all the flicks
alright but they as Mark was saying dark
universe they they were planning this
telling everybody about yeah they reveal
the cast of their massive connected
youever and they release that
information like suspiciously about two
weeks yeah
when for anybody under chance to see it
but also like when the tracking number
says so they knew they're like [ __ ] we
got to do some [ __ ] work to get these
numbers up so they start you know hey
guess what Johnny Depp is going to be
the Invisible Man and now I'll be our
bottom is going to be Frankenstein and
stuff to keep people kind of interested
looks Photoshop together a picture of
all these dudes in a room fellas on
board
and then it reviews it and like there it
is saying it's like Tom Cruise it's the
worst review Tom Cruise movie since
losing it which is going way Wow
and oh by the way I got a bone to pick
losing it's an amazing movie yeah don't
[ __ ] with losing yeah come on don't
retro actively [ __ ] cake you don't
have to [ __ ] on some to raise something
else up or in this case you don't [ __ ]
on though there's a bunch of [ __ ]
already taken care over here it's got
[ __ ] Rorschach in it Oh [ __ ] yeah
right so it's kind of conflict movie
awesome so to put this in perspective
thirty two million dollars the upper end
of perspective go do it it will be the
lowest opening among the studio's
previous mummy entrance which includes
scorpion cane which includes the 1999
mummy which opened a 43 million mummy
returns
sixty-eight point 1 million and then
mummy 2 of the Dragon Emperor 40 point 4
million and even the Dwayne Johnson
spin-off the Scorpion King which opened
a 36 million and this was all like we're
not even adjusting for time these are
real gear of numbers yeah the guy right
now is probably going up a storm's
Debbie
Frasier's so y'all thought you could do
without rage huh well [ __ ] yourselves
Dudley do-right says go [ __ ] yourself
they thought me out as as Mosby no man
and then see no men's telling you to go
[ __ ] I met him once they're nice guy
logging out of an elevator at the Four
Seasons Hotel New York Brendan Fraser
Haggadah and I was going into an
elevator and he was at The Mummy height
of his Mugen magic powers and [ __ ] and I
was going in a fire he was getting off
another elevator and he literally
doubled back and held my elevator be
like Kevin hey man I'm Brendan Fraser
I don't know out of class and I was like
suck my [ __ ] monkey bone you made a
movie movie without me he could at what
world do we live in where Tom Cruise
wants to do a mummy movie and that mummy
movies not going to do all the business
you know I mean he's not the mummy like
well although I've read a review and
there are time spoilers the quick the
feel though you know they saw these
numbers on oh babe is gone he is the
mummy from time to time she infuses him
the spirit gets him and then he starts
any other moment in the trailer they got
Russell Crowe going takes a monster -
[ __ ] monster so and they show Tom
Cruise with living skills right you do
see is like little eyes did it split
people - landing
I hear that they debut mr. Hyde as well
okay Russell Crowe you know he played
for a voice of reason of dr. Jekyll but
then when he goes mr. art he's like Oi
like he's very competent his Dick Van
Dyke clean [ __ ] Jim Knight Bob
Hoskins
I might go just for that I mean I will
go because if there's anything that I
love as much as a great movie it's a
[ __ ] horrible that's why we're
friends
there is something there's something
like confidence boost inspiring about a
movie that exists at this level and it
still so bad gives you hope makes you go
back you want to I can make it but damn
one of these days get my ass behind a
camera make a shitty movie just like
this yeah The Mummy unfortunately it
doesn't look like it's going to work out
for
this summer no that's already shooting
Mission Possible six and yeah
co-starring guys Superman can be Calvin
cattle Don yeah we went to get a recipe
for success Henry Cavill is a charming
[ __ ] dude in everything besides
Superman's look what the figures enter
sorry he's great a magnum uncle a lot of
fun it's the beginning of the dark
universe but is at the end is univer if
it goes right in the [ __ ] if it
doesn't even hit like let's say it's
impossible but let's say it doesn't even
hit 67 life is their world where they
like that focus I mean it'll do open it
wants with Dracula untold yeah I mean
it'll do okay overseas like it's not
it's it's it's somewhat stop cruise
overseas kept it in the States but
[ __ ] they're making that a Pacific
Rim and that movie didn't do gangbusters
here but it did amazing in China amazing
overseas in Asia enough to get a sequel
I feel like they're going to make the
Bill Condon Bride of Frankenstein
because it's a smart play it's bill kind
of the do to make gods and monsters
which is all about and also know Khan
and who directed [ __ ] Beauty and the
Beast yes if I'm Universal just like rub
your magic steak on up to as we can't
puck and figure it up unless it's a car
go fast route you could go drop it we
are fought alpha we want to put a put in
the rich number in that is that cool
you've directed musicals you can make
that happen
tell stop us before we put a mention to
the [ __ ] thing we don't know we're
doing but that'll be all over [ __ ]
Universal Studios Hollywood Franken
minions frickin you know they will
[ __ ] do that know like the only way
to say the dark your dark universe say
that is to throw some minions yes just
looking grew well shenana
Oh funny save touching be not so dark
universe and that ooh in an asterisk see
Despicable universe then you got the kid
okay
alright man so what else we got we got
one last thing
Sony is doing a weird little Oni Oni to
spider-man homecoming what indeed they
keep releasing more and more footage of
this movie and it is [ __ ] up seriously
I can't get enough ivory watch all the
footage that's seen not just the
trailers but now on Disney Channel
they'll do like
on the scene ah Mahlon show he's like
this Masai efforts don't depend he'll do
a stunt and they show you footage from
the movie that isn't any of the trailers
overall like when we had cable back in
the 80s we rambled and at night
sometimes we unscramble you got a little
like 30 seconds like you're gone here's
Emma doing repress Channel 13 and
channel number 92 and then move this
little [ __ ] lever and then I get
electric blue I see Josh ID watch oh
good show of show show show show Tony
right now every little piece of footage
they show me I'm just like haha this
movie looks amazing and I spoke to some
folks yesterday because they went and
did behind the scenes thing for their
blu-ray release that crazy spider-man
homecoming is not out and they're
working on the blu-ray core and they
deliver the movie they deliver the
blu-ray and stuff that comes out a few
months later so I did like you know uh
spider-man deep dive with characters and
I worked with some cats man and yeah
they they they did not spoil anything
because of course they all signed NDA's
and steadily dance your information but
they have seen the movie and you know I
told them what my bar was I said this
summer like and unless anything better
comes out between now and Christmas from
my money my favorite movie of the year
the best movie of 2017 so far as guard
needs a galaxy vol 2 one movie that I've
seen three times paid SEMA theater
stays with me all the time I think about
it it odd moments of the day think about
scenes think about like just just little
dopey things listen to the soundtrack on
full blast all the time so that movie
like really burrowed in like a like a
[ __ ] into my brain and heart and [ __ ]
like that wonderful woman very close
right after that but there's a good
chance and also we got Thor coming and
that trailer made me nut without such we
together we had Logan
we got Thor comments sure I forgot about
[ __ ] loaded what [ __ ] amazing
years is but I'm telling you this
homecoming homecoming picture might
[ __ ] take the case this may be the
greatest superhero movie ever made
Michael Keaton looks fantastic it's
yeah it's all gold but any event sony
sony home we took the time to polish
their knob because here comes the other
side they they've started this
initiative called the clean avengers in
this out yes the clean version but what
they're doing is they are taking sony
movies in their catalog and sanitizing
them for I suppose children's
consumption or those easily offended by
good things like sex violence or
language they are dubbing over things
are basically turning their movies into
the airline version of movies but going
even deeper they had some example up
online of like from amazing spider-man 2
and where Peter Parker gets shot with
chest by like just shockers little
whatever the [ __ ] they've edited out him
getting hit in the chest so it's just
whatever something gets shot at him he
falls out of the sky like a Jerry Joe
villain the parachute pops out they are
neutering movies in the library so
essentially they're doing what Spielberg
did to et take those guns out of those
cops hands and put walkie-talkies in
those cops eyes so that kind of but it's
like they're turning movies in the
library into the like WPIX version of
movies and in library I love WP I've
happy memories of a wpx childhood
particularly the Yule Log only friend a
lonely boy will ever need
so there's lots of like gpk a mr. Falcon
here's what I don't understand this
already exists called network television
somebody put a movie on it that's what
happens or as Mark mentioned on a plane
so what why is this why do they think
they have a new idea I don't know and I
don't think the thing that I also don't
know if they're doing or not they don't
have to ask the filmmakers that's what
I'm curious about that they ever have to
do that for television I remember I've
been asked a few times like you know you
have the right to we oh you know what
you do if you're DG a member cuz I
remember like they hit me up about
Jersey girl they're like you know we
sold it to a network there's you know of
the net the current cut down version is
88 minutes we needed to be 86 would you
like to find the two minutes to cut out
if not we'll do it and so you know I
probably should care but I was like
complete good luck
I spent all my life looking I'm looking
for [ __ ] time to cut out a movie
- it's running like and so so yeah I
guess they do extend it to your through
GGA yeah I mean the thing of it that
they're always kind of chased me about
this kind of thing it's like if you
don't want a movie that has these things
in it don't watch that movie yeah it's
like if you if you don't want if you to
be a vegetarian don't eat like fake hot
dogs just don't eat hot dogs yeah like
that's the price you pay for not wanting
to eat meat you don't get to eat meat
not fake meat just don't eat it that's
cool
it is it seems strange and I just don't
know how much would call for it there's
any more I mean I suppose that there's a
version where like evangelicals also
want to be able to watch Tropic Thunder
but don't want all of the good parts of
Tropic Thunder then you're not allowed
to watch Tropic Thunder like that's
always been the rule why they've been in
the rules mark I'm assuming they think
there's money to be made and our
filmmakers outraged by this Seth Rogen
was not pleased at the end he treated
something funny like oh boy yeah yeah
yeah it's like you know I hope to god
they never ask me for this or they
better ask me before they do this
honestly I'm a filmmaker and I don't
care like if they want to take my movie
I've seen it happen they [ __ ] put
mall rats on ABC when Ben Affleck was an
armageddon-like before he was an
Armageddon Ben Affleck hung out at the
mall
out of that movie were ABC and there's
lockers and that's look but I you know I
just don't understand why this was a
story if I was Sony I would have quietly
just done this and that it isn't options
somewhere in the world but seems like
they made some sort of announcement
pissed a bunch of people off yeah anyway
I do business but that's just me I don't
run Sony yeah like I just I yet
mm-hmm give this man time I'm never
going to run Sony after homecoming that
movie's gonna make all the [ __ ] money
just suck out every dollar that the
[ __ ] top but that the 1% have stolen
from all of us and they're going to
[ __ ] put it into Sony's and I guess
he gets a little taste I think they get
a little piece like this we're beak a
little and by becoming my nose and OS
this is my nose ye Araneta letters why
[Laughter]
that's Albin
as far as like a good fit I mean it's
just like [ __ ] it let me do it I guess
are we gonna do it has been done before
in the past but it just feels like a
weird business to get into
here man I have mad major requests in a
world where somebody must have made this
request like I want a clean version of
Tropic Thunder here either request can I
have a dirty version of Davey and
Goliath put some dicks in it put some
boobies in it make people curse [ __ ]
Goliath [ __ ] like that you're not
familiar with David glass no claymation
from the Gumby family resource and
spends bendable dog and sponsored Bob
looked like a horse he does look like a
[ __ ] clay he's a little dog with his
conscience and it was punted by the
Church of Jesus Christ
no thanks I believe nor the Luthor's but
regardless why can't I have something
clean dirtied up turnabout is fair play
friends there you go Sony uh wood Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs now I want to
see the balls
I want a version with real balls Cloudy
with a Chance of real balls finally
which adds up meaty balls and big dicks
that's even better meaty balls big balls
the addition of big dicks was hysterical
I mean I get why not why did I go with
real balls there's a lot of celery in
that movie mine was a TV safe joke you
went for it
I did because we're dirtying things on
your Warner Brothers I'm Sony I'm like
we got a [ __ ] trim this [ __ ] out
nope uh yeah it's a bit maybe they
better go edit all those spider-man
movies users always shoot webs not that
could be offensive to somebody but like
that reminds me of what happens even
below the deck during masturbation in
the same way that like in every rock and
roll song where they're talking about
dancing they're really talking about
[ __ ] which is true they're talking
about my [ __ ] not but what Luce is
about but [ __ ] hold on let me think
just cut loose Footloose yes just
[ __ ] but if you want to go you can
going on every Superman every spider-man
movie is about masturbation this it's
about like I don't know how does this
happen well I'm sticking to the wall and
I'm covering the ship yep yeah you want
to come over I got wet
Ned what are you doing in here Peter
what's going on upstairs nothing mom
which I'm pretty sure was actually a
line nothing at Mei um I said well done
dude well I'm about to jump on you to be
like Oh Peter Parker ha ha ha J'Accuse
that's all the news imagine also then
making a cowboy bebop hey it's all
happening that's the world we live in
now man you had said like 20 years ago
they're making a cowboy be bubbly like
thank God somebody's treating comics
seriously never they're making a comic
book movie now there's so many [ __ ]
comic book movies like by the way they
don't cowboy bebop you like I answer
phones most good TV serious but oh Tom
movie wow that makes more selling stuff
but whatever it's still if you're gonna
bust me on pluggin ma oh yeah good ended
on a high note now we have done hostile
it is very somber Oh separately for
Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm Marc
Bernard come back next episodes aims at
time same bat Channel Spock ask amor
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith my boy
bebop is a TV series boom
[Music]
[Applause]
you